hello and welcome to UPS object-oriented
programming my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's w w
simply learn comm get certified get a
hat in this we're gonna cover a basic
understanding of object-oriented
programming and we'll be specifically
working in the Python interface or the
Python code oops the most basic concept
is not the accident you just had or the
mistake you just knocked her coffee cup
over off your desk but it's actually
stands for object-oriented programming
and whether you're working in Python
which we'll be doing today or in any
scripting language almost all of them
rely on object-oriented programming as
their basis programming paradigm that
focuses on objects so everything is an
object in the coding every instance in
Python is an object and again this is
true for any of the main programming
languages you know if you're working in
Java or skaila or any of these you're
gonna be looking at object-oriented
programming it just makes a lot of sense
and really is that one of the
cornerstones of today's programming and
when we talk about object in programming
an object has two different things
it has attribute as two different things
attributes which is data describing the
object and behavior methods on the
attributes so the first one is your
actual data and the second is what are
you doing to that data and if you're a
car lover we're going to use cars as an
example this is kind of easy to see how
that might fit in to the different
objects and so we're gonna start with a
BMW for example that's an object and
with the BMW you might have like the
year the manufacturer maximum speed
those would be attributes of that car
and then you have the behavior these are
methods on the attributes for example
you might display the speed or change
the speed so even though you have a
maximum speed you might have current
speed also which changes depending on
what you wanted to do step on the
accelerator go faster step on the brakes
go slower and the primary terminology
and programming is usually class and
that's definitely true in Python so
class is a collection of similar objects
in this example we have cars or class so
you might have trucks bicycles and
airplanes but in cars we have some very
specific things cars have four wheels
that are on the ground maybe a spare
hanging down headlights steering wheel
things you would expect in a car doors
to get in so it's all inside but in here
we actually have a number in the
collection we have our BMW our Ford our
Adi you can guess the guys in the back
like the BMW the best I don't blame them
and so we work with classes or
collection of items today I'm gonna use
the user-interface pycharm it's one of
the very popular Python editor I myself
have never used it so this is a new
experience for me
it's pleasantly fun to use and easy to
set up you can go to jetbrains comm
that's the people behind it so WW
jetbrains comm / pycharm / and once
you're on the PI charm if you go under
downloads you'll have two options let me
just hit the download now button they'll
take you to the two options one is a
professional which you would pay for
which allows integration between teams
and companies set up and has a bunch of
extra cool tools you need for a business
and then there's a community version
which is the lighter-weight one for the
purposes of this demo and most the work
you do the community ones probably just
fine you can download it it's open
source it's free I don't know about you
but I like open source and free and a
lot of my stuff and I've already opened
up a project file but you can create a
new project file up here I'll put a note
down in the YouTube and they can send
you some of this code or go visit simply
learn they'll send you the code itself
if you need it there's a lot of
different like I said functionality in
here
we're both mostly gonna be underneath
just run the demo in this case I'm doing
oops simply learn so we'll just be
running when I'm working in here let's
go ahead and start with creating a class
in Python and you simply just tell it
it's a class so the class means this is
gonna be our Python template whatever we
are working on I'll call this car and
this is interesting because class itself
let me just highlight that so when I put
up class here that is a Python object
and then I'm using that to build car my
class
quickly on here well let me windows
change that font I have it pretty large
already in my editor let's go back down
here to editor font and I put it up all
the way to 26 I think we can get it by
with 30 so you can really see it
hopefully that's gonna be big enough on
there and so once we have our class we
wanted to do something and so in a class
when you put the words death that stands
for definition whatever that's called
that is a function it's gonna actually
do something on there and you'll see
what I like about this is nice
with the pie chart automatically
automatically puts self in there why
because self refers to whatever the
object is no it doesn't refer to the
template class car it refers to the
instance of that and I'll show you in a
minute what that exactly means but in
this case we're gonna do something
simple we're just gonna have a print and
you see it automatically indents it so
python and if you remember or if you're
new to Python is based on indentations
you have to end in so everything under
this indent is part of the DEF
everything under class that's indented
as part of the class and so we're just
gonna look down at our speedometer and
we're gonna print 155 miles per hour
maybe son the autobahn in Europe I don't
know racetrack not very often you go 155
miles an hour in a car at least not in
my experience maybe in the future we
have auto cars that do hundreds of miles
per hour to shoot down the freeways and
let's go ahead and create an instance of
the class I will simply do BMW equals
car and we'll put brackets on there and
let's also do let's do a four four
equals car so if you remember car is
like a template is still an object so I
have BMW equals car and I have 4 equals
car these are two separate instances so
they're copying or they're actually
putting a pointer to car so everything
under car is part of BMW and the same
thing with Ford and we can do something
like this we can go car dot get speed
let's put in the BMW law or we could
also do car dot get speed forward given
the choice I think I'd go with the BMW
and there's another way you can do this
we can also do BMW
get because remember that points back to
the original template so all the
functionalities in the original template
and then we could also do Ford dot get
speed these are little bit more common
more than you'll see the top part but
let's go ahead and run this and if we go
under run we find out that alt shift f10
you can use the hotkeys which I'll
probably start doing and I just simply
hit make sure I highlight the one I'm
working on and it runs it down here and
so you can see right here we have 155
miles per hour printed out by the BMW
155 miles out printed by the Ford car
get speed and then I did in a different
format BMW get speed and for duck get
speed the thing to notice is the term
self that is a Python term which means
that when we create an instance whatever
comes in here is what's being processed
and so if I call the class or the
template directly in this case I did car
get speed I have to include what that
self is in this case it's a BMW or if
I'm calling it from the instance BMW
because it includes the car class it
knows that gets speed and it knows
automatically that this is self that's
where the term self comes in so that's
important to note in there in Python
it's a one of the more pythonic kind of
solutions is that when you see the term
self that refers to that instance did
you create it in this case the BMW
instance and the Ford instance when
you're setting up a class there's a lot
of things you can do in here there is a
key term in it what this means is that
when I create the new instance
whatever happens in here is gonna be set
sets up your information let me show you
how that works we're gonna do is we're
gonna pass your and speed in here and
this is really important is I need to
take self that's going to be the new
instance I created I'm in the K in this
example will be our BMW and our Ford and
put a period here and then year equals
year that's a variable that was passed
do the same thing with speed self dot
speed equals speed so when we create
this we now have two different variables
in here
and if you remember from our slide an
object has attributes data describing
the object and a behavior methods on the
object and so in our class or our
template we're going to knit it
initialize it and hit it we're going to
Nishal eyes it with the year and the
speed on here but if we initialize it
here when we create the instance we have
to send that information so that knows
what the year is and what the speed is
for the BMW and the Ford and that means
we create this instance let's go ahead
and do 2018 maybe this is the maximum
speed that shows up on the speedometer I
don't know but 2018 we'll put it at 155
miles per hour and then we'll take the
Ford a little bit older runs a little
slower it's a 2016 but this will be the
maximum speed we'll do 140 miles per
hour it's the fastest it can go and then
so now we've set up some data on our
object right here coming through and so
BMW now has a a year-and-a speed and so
does Ford and when we get speed let's go
ahead and change this and in fact I'm
gonna do so I let's just get rid of this
middle part because I tend to do the
standard BMW get speed and we'll call
this maximum speed maximum speed is and
then we'll just put down self a speed so
that's our variable so that's whatever
the instance is so self speed is gonna
refer to our BMW or our Ford and if we
go ahead and run this and that was go up
here to run and alt shift f10 I'm just
gonna do alt shift f10 it's already set
to the tab I'm on hit enter and we come
down here and you can see had an error
there this is a double underline for the
anit the code that they sent me had just
a single and I forgot to double check
that so we have a double underline in it
it comes in here and speed the BMW has
2018 with the maximum speed of 155 and
when we print that out BMW get speed
you'll see it right here the maximum
speed is 155 and then it does it for the
Ford maximum speed is 140 and then we're
done processing it so we've stored some
data in here we stirred the year we
stored the speed and then we've had a
process on that data in
is to go ahead and just print it out
print out the self dot speed and let's
go ahead and briefly look at
encapsulation def set speed self speed
so we're gonna send it a new speed value
to set the speed and from here we'll go
ahead and do self dot speed equals speed
and we'll just work with the BMW on this
one let's take the Ford out of there for
a moment and we have our Ford get speed
and we're going to set the speed and the
new speed is going to be oh let's make
it one forty three just an odd number so
it's easy to see and then we'll go ahead
and do BMW dot get speed and when we go
ahead and run this I'll do the alt shift
f10 and run it as you can see here it
comes out it says 155 because that's
what the speed was when we first entered
in it and then we went ahead and changed
it BMW set speed and is now 143 so you
can see here how we can alter the
information in our template and if we
remember we had the Ford the Ford is
completely separate from this so if we
still have Ford down here equals car
2016 140 if we still had that down here
this 143 isn't gonna affect the Ford at
all because this for instance is
separate from the BMW so if I do Ford
get speed and we do an alter ship f10 to
run it there we go here's our Ford 140
so it hasn't changed even though we did
we set the speed on the BMW to 143 the
first thing we want to look at is
inheritance and so inheritance is a
mechanism for a new class to use the
features of another class and if you've
ever done like word processing you might
use a template from that template you
can have all kinds of stuff you put into
the template and you can save it in
different instances depending on what
you're doing and then those particular
instances you saved could be used as a
template for your next thing I use that
all the time when I was in cells I would
where I'd do some cells on the side as
part of my job working with them to
support them and build a software for
them we build put together a document
and then we take that document they'd
become the template for the next three
documents that are very similar this is
the same way you have a class and from
that class we can inherit everything
from there and then make changes on it
we're gonna go ahead and cover let's do
this for BMW just close that up take
this out of here for now okay let's go
ahead and do inheritance that's where
we're going to take the class car and
we're going to bring all these features
from class car into a new template or a
new class let's start with a class sedan
and the sedan is gonna inherit from car
so it's gonna bring a car in and now we
have a sedan coming down once we create
the sedan this is now a child class two
car coming down and under this class
I'll just go ahead and we'll just type
in a deaf accelerate course self and on
here we're just gonna have it print and
this have a do let's say I would do one
hundred and fifty that seems like very
high let's go 133 just because well like
the 133 this change it to 137 there we
go and then let's do another one here
we'll do this class SUV and it also is
going to inherit from car and this too
is a child class of car so we'll just
put a label there so we can remember
that and we'll also give it an
accelerate and when we do an accelerate
keep the self and we'll print let's see
this year or whatever production is 180
I don't know why that seems awfully high
first SUV versus a sedan let's do 127
maybe goes a little bit slower than the
sedan there we go so let's go and hit
enter on there and let's take a look at
what we got going here I have my BMW I
have my forward and let's add a Honda
and we're gonna make it equal to the
sedan and just for fun that's add one
more thing def open trunk self a little
bit print trunk has been opened there we
go
so take a look and see we got going here
I've created my Honda if you remember up
above we have our BMW I'll just
just the BMW get speed and then I want
to do the Honda get speed and when we
run this we can see our BMW is 155 and
our maximum speed on our Honda is a
hundred and fifty because that's that we
set I remember this inherited it from
cars so this an it is now part of the
sedan the open trunk if we do this if I
go the other way around let's say oh
let's do this let's do the Honda open
trunk and then we'll do just throw an
error here this is going to give us an
error it doesn't even auto type it for
me I'm still do alt shift f10 and run it
and you can see down here is that we had
our BMW get speed okay there's our 155
we had our Honda get speed we had our
Honda open the trunk and because our car
we go up here to car does not have open
trunk the BMW does not have that
definition so it gives us an error so we
can't do that unless we add that to the
top as part of a car it just turns out
though that let me just take the BMW out
for whatever reason this BMW doesn't
have a trunk I think they all have
trunks but that's okay for this example
we'll just leave it like that so you can
see right here we've inherited and then
we've gone ahead and added new features
to our new class so this child class of
sedan has come in here now has both
accelerate open trunk the SUV which
we're gonna look at in just a second
also has open trunk so we've had a lot
of functionality we have our original
car template so when whatever setup up
here comes down here and then we've
added both accelerate let me just do
that right here or Honda can accelerate
the Honda and if we run that you can see
the Honda has their acceleration come in
and prints out in this case 137 down
here that's what I like to mark it with
a weird number like 137 so you can tell
the difference where we're going this we
have our accelerator so we've added
features into our sedan encapsulation is
a important feature preventing data from
direct access and this is we called
encapsulation we'll discuss that more
later on but what it means in this
particular case is that
when you create a class from another
class you can't alter the original
template the child class can make all
its own changes to that class and do all
kinds of things but it can't make any
direct changes to the parent let's go
ahead and take a look at encapsulation
in the code itself so we can have a
better idea what we're talking about so
we have our class car we have our
definitions here's our an it this is
from if you remember from the last slide
we had our knit maybe we've had a couple
more functions to it or modules to it
and we have get speed and set speed all
of this under class car is encapsulated
what that means is that if I create an
instance of it in this case I'm going to
create a BMW wouldn't that be nice if I
can just whip out a BMW make a BMW when
we create our instance BMW it does not
change the class car this whatever we do
to this instance does not make changes
to our class and the same thing with the
Ford the BMW doesn't get speed it might
do something here in the definitions
under the class but the initial class if
I create another car let's say we take
our BMW we set the speed for 155 like we
did here and we create a Ford whatever I
do with the 4 does not change the class
car and if I create like we did before
with our inheritance a subclass that's
not going to change the class car that's
what they call encapsulate it bundles
things together and it really is central
to oops object-oriented programming is
we're basically bundling things together
and then we keep them in a nice safe
bundle and anything we do from that we
either point to it and say hey let's use
this definition or we make a copy of it
so we kind of do a combination of there
and say ok here's our new inheritance
but you can see right here this is
encapsulation and again that's like
central - oops
this is how UPS was originally
discovered created and found it is when
they realized hey why don't we just
bundle things together instead of
rewriting the code over and over and
over and then pulling morphism we talked
about encapsulation in classes just
recently like I said we'll go in this
and we can open up the code polymorphism
is we take the feature in the code and
then we can alter that feature so we can
use the same function in multiple ways
that's a lot of fun a lot of power in
that let's go ahead and take our
totally morphism and take a look at it
what's going on in the actual code we're
writing our Python code so here we have
our parent class car and we switch
colors here we have a sedan where we
inherited the car and an SUV also an
inheritance
look at this we have a peer or an it so
let me just put so we have our
definition we're initializing it the
first class we met it in accelerate so
what that means is with their
acceleration that's not part of the
initial car class right now until we add
it in so we have our definition
accelerate which print 150 miles per
hour so all sedans have a print of 150
we need to accelerate all other cars
don't have anything going on in them
right now and then with SUV we're gonna
define the accelerate differently so we
have the accelerate down here with self
print 180 so we have two different
polymorphs going on here we have
accelerate one polymorph going on in
this example we've added accelerate to
both of these classes and so it doesn't
matter which one I accelerate its gonna
do something and so if we create in this
case we're gonna create an object down
here an instance of it do this in pink
here's our instances that's a little
light let's do something a little darker
than that one there we go so we have our
instances and we're gonna create one
object which is a sedan a Camry and one
object which is an SUV Scorpio and then
we can just go through the objects we
can actually just loop through the
objects one object at a time and if we
do print object name and end we have our
object name so it's gonna print the name
in this case I'll print Camry and I'll
print Scorpio and then we have object
accelerate and for the sedan since
that's our Camry it's gonna print the
hundred and fifty and for the SUV it's
gonna print 180 for the Scorpio and so
by doing this we polymorph the same
definition to do two different things
depending on what our child classes so
we can pull more of all kinds of things
and we'll actually look at a couple more
objects in there when you go through the
full code later on there's a couple more
examples in this but this is a
polymorphism coming down and you can see
how we able to leverage the same name
for the definition to do different
things depending on what our object is
thank you for joining us today for loops
object oriented
graeme by simply learned ww simply
learned comm come join us
check out the classes feel free to join
our forums and post questions you have
on there or if you have questions on
this video you can post them down below
in the youtube comment section and we
will be monitoring that again thank you
for joining us happy learning and have a
great day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified
click here